[موسيقى]
السيدات والسادة ، البداية
حفل التوقيع الروسي
وثائق مصرية من تاريخ الحديقة
top del rosin إلى الجمهور أو العنوان الذي
تقريبا أنا روس وزيرا للخارجية
الاتحاد الروسي سيرجي فيكتوروفيتش
لافروف ووزير الشؤون العربية
جمهوريات مصر اسف
من فضلك قاطعني آسف
بوروزا دميتري غابي ابنة أبزال اليسار
رحلة شكرا جزيلا لك آسف
إرضاء كل خير وداعا
[تصفيق]
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي فلاديمير
فلاديميروفيتش بوتين والرئيس العربي
جمهوريات مصر يطلقون النار على صور الكسر
توقيع اتفاقية بين الروس
اتحاد جمهورية مصر العربية
على شراكة شاملة و
التعاون الاستراتيجي
حماتورة بخرز من زوجات البحر من الزبالة
وجولة قمامة من فلاديمير بوتين تثير روسي
أليكسيا الثاني كانت هذه الحقائق والعنة
الحائز على جائزة الفكر العربية
بروكسل انها تذهب وأعد دروسنا
Shamilya من thraun bistro you
[تصفيق]
حفل التوقيع يسير على قدم وساق
بيان الرئيس الروسي
اتحاد فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش بوتين
ورئيس جمهورية مصر العربية
بقية فتاحة السيسي
لوسائل الإعلام و
صرخ في وجهه من الحشد
لا يزال سرا وشريط أنا لست الشركة نفسها
صد ستائر نيسان هاماتور ، خفضت
العنصرية لا قمامة سخيف رائحة الصباح بالخارج
فلاديمير بوتين السفر روس العزيز
السيدات والسادة الأصدقاء الأعزاء وقال
tassadar الذي كريم قبلنا
أبلغك بنتيجة
عمل اليوم
يتصرف سخيف nato lacquers 0 زوج التوت مثل هذا
يود أن يقول أن القليل
منذ ساعات
حدث طارئ في روسيا في مدينة كييف
حدث مأساوي قالت إنها ماء
الركبة هذه الحديقة بالضبط حجم سارة.
رد كافيه روسي في الانفجار
قتل عبوة ناسفة معدة
لاحظ العديد من الجرحى الخط
وهي البقية الضعيفة من السموم و
Kabirova من الفندق.
المدار في الواقع أريد أن أعبر عنه
تعازي أسر الضحايا و
أعرب عن أمله في أن الضحايا
تتحسن وبأسرع وقت ممكن كلنا
لهذا اجعلها هي وماءها
معامل آسيا
أولبيا ليو أو فندق أتامان
طاهٍ غير مرغوب فيه
المصري بالفعل الغذاء الآن ما هو عليه
جريمة مياه الأمل لكنها ليست كذلك
وتغيير دوافع وإصدارات هذا
مأساة
مدروسة بعناية خاصة مجالات الين
لعربة تيدا تراس فندق المرحلة
ونتيجة لهذا العمل
إنفاذ القانون والخاصة
خدمات
سيتم إبلاغ الجمهور
اختار خطط الرئيسي معي
الزوج هو marusei بينياتا ولعبة الدردشة
كانت التعليقات ضد الفوضى في روسيا و
أصدقائي الأعزاء
تعرف على الموتى ، أسألك أن تكرم
دقائق ذاكرتهم هي جدا أنا ولكن آل
عازار البروتينات الأخرى إما لأن لذلك والتاريخ
[موسيقى]
عزيزي حضره الرئيس
سيداتي وسادتي ، أنا جنة المنقذ
كتلة هذه الحديقة
مفاوضات مع رئيس مصر
يقع في روسيا مع مسؤول
زار للعمل و
البيئة البناءة والنخيل
هواة وآلامهم يزيد من آلامه
من أجل الفائز
موقع mocap مع صور أسيزي
أنا سعيد بسترة تغليف الحلوى من سوبوف
لدينا من خلال السيد الرئيس في
لوحة موافق غير رسمية
تحدثت عن التعلم على مجموعة كاملة من
مشاكل
هذا اللغز القلق الفيزيائي الإيروسميث
معركة لوتا أبيلارد أوليا يونغ
ناقشت أديدا المجمع بأكمله اليوم
قضايا التعاون الثنائي
استعرضت الرئيسية الدولية و
محارب المشاكل الإقليمية لديك هناك
يساوي بي وأرسل هذا السعر و
حزين لبعيد انها انت
فرع الجندي فرع الرمل الإجهاد
احترام دولتنا غنية
التاريخ ودود و
الطبيعة ذات المنفعة المتبادلة و
التواريخ تتاراتاتا الروسية رأس الحربة إما
انها تحت الرواسب من تحديد
أنها تقوم على الاحترام والمراعاة
مصالح بعضهم البعض
ما هدفه killiana ذلك على الإطلاق
منتصف أوليا الذهاب رومانوفا
يكتبون دور ماكس الجص القديم مثلك
لقد رأينا للتو رئيس السيسي
وقعت اتفاقية شاملة
الشراكة والاستراتيجية
التعاون فيه
مهام جادة ومسؤولة
مزيد من تعميق الروسية
اتصالات مصرية بعدة طرق
التعريفة الخاضعة للظواهر لمجلدين
زيارة راسا في عداد المفقودين على نطاق واسع
تحليل واتا شاميلية لاستراتيجيات لعنة
بالابينا
تخصيص الرسوم ونغمة العطاء عن جاليا
الصيف
كعك تاميكا ليباتوف وعلى وبالطبع
كان الاهتمام الكبير للمفاوضات
مخصصة للتجارة والموضوعات الاقتصادية
تذاكر أوليج تيمو ماس تعطي التحديث
نا وو لا لا لا لا الممثلة
القيام والتسلسل في حجم 2017
التجارة المصرية الروسية
بنسبة 62 في المئة
حرب داتاباد لنفسي ريبي في روسيا أنا
إلى المكتب الرئيسي على telema ، أنهي الأيام جيدًا
زلابية جدا بلغت 6.7 مليار
المتأنق la-la-ba-leha حتى هذا
كلاهما يخشى على مدى مليار سنة
نما شهر يناير - أغسطس من قبل 2 آخر من الحلال لدينا
المدينة هناك هم خلايا النحل وداغستان
ثبت ركوب الكيمياء الحيوية روسيا
مورد رئيسي
سنحصل على المارصية بالحبوب للسوق المصري
جمع و hailea السيد فول أليك
بلادنا تدعم التطلعات
مصر
إبرام اتفاق بشأن منطقة حرة
التجارة مع الاقتصاد الأوراسي
الهدف فاينا روسي جولة روبوتات فاتنة
السيد يدق الجماعية 5 مايو المزواة
هناك تاجر
سيفتح فرصًا إضافية لـ
اقتصادي
التعاون لزيادة التجارة
دوران ش هي هناك هي أنت ولكن أساءت لك
صور القطط تتباطأ هل هي في الكل
أمريكا ثم كل شيء من آلان أليكسيس دي
إناء أنا تاريخ تاباتا على تفاصيل دعابة
أوقفه رئيس مصر
قضايا التعاون الثنائي في
طاقة الأفوكادو ليكا على كاشين
استقر decalitres ، وإلا توقفنا و
بدأ من أبي
مشروع مشترك رئيسي في هذا
صناعة الانتصاب روس هذا أنت مصر
محطة للطاقة النووية الروسية
التصميم
ألما شعارات الفيا دلما آسف على كلاهما
moffat جديد و القمامة في الملعب
بدأ العمل التحضيري
بحلول نهاية العام من المقرر أن يوقع
عقود مع شركات مصرية
التي من المفترض أن تشارك بنشاط
كمقاولين من الباطن بواسطتك
ثم قالت انها تنتو نيكل أمل هذه الفكرة
علم فندق فيات ريتمو سولاريس
مجرفة وميض نهر سانا مينالي بالحليب
حسنًا ، ما نوع ونوع هذا النهر من ماشا
وقفت تاما أوديسا
لكن كرة الفيلم كانت تجربة إيجابية
التعاون على الشراء في الميدان
تنمية الموارد الهيدروكربونية
إنه بعيد عن البيانات ويأخذ الأنواع و yefim
آسف للصورة سوف نفذت
التسليم المنتظم للروسية
المنتجات البترولية والغاز الطبيعي المسال للسوق المصري
اخرج أوليج من أزاروف روسيا أو موكاب
رتب البيت من الأعضاء إليه رحمه الله
محطة الحافلات في سياق التنمية
يود التعاون الصناعي أن
فقط لذكر عقد كبير
بقيمة 1 مليار يورو للإمداد
مصر لسيارات الركوب مع
الشريكان المجريان فيرسانوف وبوشهر
أو هذه الحقائق التي تغلبت عليها Cybera
مليار أدوار الصيف الفاشية أميليو الجنة
شيرو ألفا هنا لدي روبوت سيء
قطر أم قناع بمشاركة روسيا في
مصر في منطقة قناة السويس
صناعية حديثة
المنطقة اللوجستية بما في ذلك الأجهزة
النجارة البناء
شركات الأدوية في
ماي ماسترز في ليون بولوك
إنشاء فيلم إنشا منتا لابنه وروسي مع الحاخام
قال مكتب قبعة bouillabaisse أوليا هذا في سن
الصلاة متعددة detalii هذا هو آثوس وما بعده
قيلولة ألما دي خطة لرسم
الاستثمار في هذا المجال حوالي 7 مليار دولار
دولار أكثر من 35 ألف عامل جديد
الأماكن ومن آل يطير تلك الساعة ب المتهم
دقيقة منا يحفز كل من المصلحات على الثعالب
مارات.
حسنًا ، شروط حمص هنا هي ليتين أليف شيشا
المنتجات المصنوعة في هذا المجال
من المتوقع أنها لن تذهب فقط
في مصر والشرق الأوسط و
في السوق الأفريقية التذكارية 2nm
بينما رجال الاطفاء بخير ديفي ل
كان على مينتاكا حل هذه المشكلة بينما كنت تلعب كرة الغابة
بالإضافة إلى من فندق فاليا كينج إلى مقهى وفواكه
ناقش بالتفصيل الآفاق
التعاون العسكري التقني ل
بعيدة ، فهي دقيقة في التذاكر الخطرة asel
foros الصيف لدينا لعنة الجليل الملتوية
هم على نفس القدر من الأهمية هو الجيش
تفاعلات طلاء اظافر دلك
ألدر مدينة الملح ألاسكا روسيا ومصر
يتفاعل الناجح على هذه
وجهات لعقود
روسيا تحصل على درجة الماجستير في مدرسة fe-1 الخاصة بنا
آسف أوليا أوليا نموذج okud
هذه الأيام في الأراضي المصرية
يخضع لتدريبات تكتيكية مشتركة
القوات المحمولة جوًا في أنا و ofigeli
أيضا yefima إلى تكتيكات القديمة على البوابة أنا
ميدالية فندق ليبو من روسيا مصر
يظهر دائما
وتظهر
التراث الروحي للثقافة الشيقة
شعوبنا ناه أرقام روس الجنية
في الروسية قبل
موسترا ولكن أين ديمان كأشخاص احصائيات وفاليا
لجافا الشمس
تمت الموافقة على العلاقات مع رئيس cesi
مبادرة للإعلان عن عام 2020
عبور عام العمل الإنساني
التعاون في حالة وجود كبريت روسي جديد
1by
ما إذا كان المشهد الحقيقي للكأس قد تم سلخه
هيونغ سانا التي لم تضغط عليها أليس
روس الاموسا
نظر في مسألة الاستعادة
مؤسسة كاملة النطاق
تبادلات سياحية كاملة
الحركة الجوية وعند نهر بوسني لك
المطى أوليج كلتا الفرشتين هي صورة badoglio
يلمع كاميل على اللقلق في دائرة الضوء وكذلك
الكامل أبريل في دنتال لينج
رحلات منتظمة مباشرة على الطريق
موسكو fio و نيسان أرمادا
جوز توماس ti-anov عالق أنا وفير
كم عالم اليوم ناقشناه أيضًا
مسألة رحلات الطيران العارض في
تحظى بشعبية بين السياح الروس
الاتجاهات إلى الغردقة وشرم الشيخ
صب على الشاطئ على كتلة النموذج أو
انعكاس المعاقل المعدنية و
وقابل للقسمة على القهوة على وجه الخصوص
فورد كا سيارتك لوحظ أن لدينا
الأصدقاء المصريون يفعلون كل ما هو ضروري
من أجل رفع المستوى
الأمان
الخاص بك arno البلياردو أنا ولكن sdk أنها تقريبا
المطر أنا koeman
كول مافيا بدؤوا في المنزل 0 نحن
سنسعى ل
الوقت القادم لاستئناف رحلات الطيران العارض
النقل يحلق طريقك معها أو
من ti-ans
جوز لياد ألفا و ألمو بشيرة فيفا
مهنة التمثيل
خسرت المفاوضات أن روسيا مصر
التمسك بالمطابقة أو جدا
إغلاق المراكز الحالية
القضايا الدولية والإقليمية
ألما بافا اليموفا
على الرغم من حجم جين مثل هذا المرات المغرة
صخرة الهجوم في الكتاب به سجل
عيد الفصح الروسي
menabo بكثير قبل lemigo مزدوج حقيقي
تعاون دولنا دائما
كان ولا يزال
عامل فعال في ضمان
الأمن في الشرق الأوسط و
شمال أفريقيا
وإلا فهو روسي سريع تقريبًا
لا يزل هو سارة paylin fi والمنزل
ورقة الملك مين فيشر أوراق من الخاص بك
ثم أبلغ ماليفك زملائنا
حول الخطوات التي اتخذتها روسيا ل
تسوية الوضع في سوريا
يوم hubbard a palmas 3 0 futura taruse
لقد راجعت نوعًا ما الأفلام باستخدام سورة wi-fi
مشاهدة هذه المشكلة والاتفاق عليها
عمل مشترك
الأبيض الاباحية الشرج الحمار فراغ مشكلة
وافق bta atari by Sofia 30
الأمر الذي يتطلب اهتماما خاصا
شئون محافظة ادلب حقيقة علي
zameli alimov rey و لكن هجمات ألينا
تيمو ماس
أوليميا في Sole و Mintaka هل أنت في أي مكان
تراكمت منطقة خفض التصعيد بشكل كبير
عدد المسلحين
هناك خطر انتشارهم في الجوار
حالة
ظاهرة مثل قاعة أكتوبر
القمامة دور علوي أوبي وان الكترا
المزارع
سواء تمسكنا أو أحادي الأذن
أبلغ أصدقائنا المصريين عنه
ما يكمن في صميم الاتفاق مع
تركيا لحل هذه المشكلة
أفوكادو لكو أخبار ناسداك هي ألما
عواء ماكدونالدز بناء صورة الواقع
واجهة الخليج في روسيا th الأتراك
وافق wsus على مواصلة التنسيق مع
بهدف تنشيط السوري
العملية السياسية هي حقيقة على
فيلم الأناناس أتذوق
كتلة روسيا 7 كتلة روسيا آمنة بعد ذلك
في ضوء سوريا دعني أذكرك أن المصري
شجع الأصدقاء على المشاركة في
المؤتمر الوطني السوري
حوار في سوتشي
جزء من المعارضة من بين من يسمى
منصة كورية قلقت هي
محمي عقوبة لا بالماس ثلاث خطوات
ليتر ابادون وانت تطير اقواس الجواب
ماتس raffia البذاءات الصراخ hovard asura هو
الرمال الآن المهمة هي أن تكون
تشكلت وأطلقت
اللجنة الدستورية لجنيف
Valya Valya Omiya رايون و Tashkin
الدرج إلى الكراسي و suriya في نفس الوقت
يمكن بذل جهد جماعي
لاستعادة الاقتصاد نفسه بعد
Dalek oleina لقد وضعت عضلاتك
سكاكين جراد البحر اللبن على السورة لخلق
ظروف مواتية من أجل
عودة لاجئي وايتهول أسورا
Angouleme و adepts re-lise
ستستمر ميجا سورة روسيا مصر
البحث المشترك عن طرق للتغلب عليها
الانقسام السياسي الداخلي في ليبيا
استعادة السيادة و
وحدة أراضي البلاد
rusya أنت تتقن مع هذا بينك
الناس يعيشونها ، أنا لم أرتديها وأيزوبيل
آل
مقهى Gelendzhik libya wyatt teste
كارفال أمين تفاصيلي هذا قبل أوليغا زيد
صحافة روسيا ومصر في صالح
التقيد بالمبادئ
الاستيطان الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي
القرارات المنصوص عليها في القرارات
مجلس الأمن الدولي والعربي
مبادرة السلام روس أحضرت لك أسترا
دورات على مدار الساعة البومة لقد عشت أكثر من ذلك بكثير
ديما اين البنك اذن هو حاد من فضلك
أوليا امتص الكمامة بينما أنا أجرة ألما المزدوجة
أثناء الجري ومتى نحن معه إذن
تحرك لك الموضة
المو بدرة العربية أنفسهم وخلفهم
استئناف فوري للحوار المباشر
بين الطرفين في جميع النزاعات
بما في ذلك مكانة القدس
بينما جزء من 2 أو ألبا فوتو تالما
bashira 3 0 a grass attanasia le le
مانا الأريكة ليلي ليما سلمى بت
لم يأكل ضوء قليلا بينا كود في عام 2019
مصر ستترأس
الاتحاد الأفريقي في المنصب لقد ماتت للتو
هذا الأخير في سن الماجستير
مع فندق تاراس علي تيه أفريقيا الذي نتمناه
لجميع أصدقائنا المصريين و
النجاح في هذا
مسؤول
إنها هناك توقع بسهولة أنها تمطر تقريبًا
واحة الشيطان عليرا جزء من جلسة
ناديا دبليو وآدم أليس يتطلعان إلى ذلك
الرئاسة المصرية
تعزيز التعاون
روسيا مع كل دول افريقيا
معجبين أنانوري الأسد سيد علي
منفصلة عن أفريقيا القاتلة هو أ
حزين ذ أنفسنا فيلم تاكسي صور أونابي
روس مع الخضار حصة أفريقيا أنا وفي
خاتمة أود أن أشكر
السيد الرئيس لدينا كل
أصدقاء مصريين للتثقيف
مفاوضات مثمرة ، لأنه بالفعل
سباق السيارات
جلسة فلاديمير زناكا مسلين علي بابا
سادهاني تل مجنون بالطيران بها
النتائج التي تحققت اليوم
سيساهم بالتأكيد
زيادة تعزيز
البشر من عندنا
ale ti fatality tomato أنت هي أو عنه
جلس مع أوضاع المافيا وموشوم
أكاتوف على موقع ئي باي على الأغنياء
شكرا لك على الاختيار ك انتر
أرسم Pepeliaev 2 للكيراتين
العالم كله بدون سيف للجماهير من أصدقاء السيارات
والأصدقاء ، أعشاب من الفصيلة الخبازية وجميع في المقابل الرئيس
السماح نيابة عنك شخصيًا نيابة عن
الشعب المصري الذي طورته لك
وأعرب عن خالص تعازيه
ناس روس
خالص التعازي
الحوادث المأساوية التي حدثت
اليوم في روسيا أ ، زيل أعلاه مفتوحة
لا طعام فاريجة بنات خالص
التعازي لذوي الضحايا و عاجلا
التعافي
مصاب بمليار أخلاق في العاشر
المترو من فلاديمير بوتين
هذا oheda adobe leiden بدأ mugabe
واحد مع 2 حالة مرفوعة في ورقة وهنا
ب ل حول الإطار حول تحليل الخلل
لحظة هؤلاء الأتراك حتى خارج الفندق
الخريطة 3.03 و علاء توت المدار bein miss
لا روسي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
عزيزي السيد الرئيس بوتين السيدات
وسادتي ، أود مرة أخرى
شكرا صديقي العزيز
الرئيس بوتين على الترحيب الحار و
خلال هذا كرم مهم
زيارة والتي تؤكد و
تنعكس القوة من قريبة التاريخية
العلاقات بين مصر وروسيا وأكثر
عن غير قصد لاعبين وراء هجوم كوندا ليكسا
خاركوف لكتائب زيكو من الجيش
سروال
موديلات اوليا امانار بيكر ماء وصغير
مثل قبالة والحراس العارية عدة مرات أنا
كبير وهناك يستنشق بال تاين
المطا يعبث بعيد الصراخ.
ألمآتا مرحلة جديدة ويسرني
وجودي هنا للتعبير عن بلدي
الرضا مع النجاح الكبير في
العلاقات الروسية المصرية
السنوات الأربع الماضية والإنجازات
تحقق في جميع المجالات
بقيادة توقيع اتفاق بشأن
إنشاء محطة للطاقة النووية من أجل
أنا من الجد الدردشة عبر الإنترنت
قمة قوية هذه المدينة لا تشتري
الدماغ مرتفع فقط
موتو حسنه و سراويل و
كهف الدورة ولطائرة الهليكوبتر لدينا 10
المعمار الدخان حصة هذا الحزن وعلى
مهالي تونت هي الاحلام والابي ايسر
أعشارنا هذه الصواريخ من الجميع
الغش زوجين الغابات وكالة سفر الأمسيات رغوة
أعتقد أن هذا المشروع بدون أي
الشك سيخلق قفزة نوعية في
العلاقات بين بلدينا و
أيضا مشروع لإنشاء روسي
ذاكرة الوصول العشوائي الصناعية
في المنطقة الشرقية من ميناء سعيد المنازل
تم تصميم هذا المشروع لجلب
التعاون بين دول الاتحاد الأوروبي
مرحلة تبادل السلع البسيطة إلى المسرح
إنتاج مشترك وأنا متأكد من ذلك
تنفيذ هذا المشروع لخلق
طفرة حقيقية في الحجم والجودة
الاستثمار الروسي المباشر في مصر
اعثر على الكحل عندما أعمى الدوري دينامو
نسخ الديناصور ألفا تستا دهب
له يدفع الناس على الحفرة ويدفع
وابتعدوا عن الإنفاق بالآلاف ، اللعنة
وحدد حديقة fastlane الذكية أو oleg
انها ديربي جنبا إلى جنب ارتفاع الصرف 2 هانم
إلخ.
الأجهزة الكهربائية للكوكتيلات والسرطان
استراتيجيات الفندق جهودنا المشتركة
تعزيز علاقة الصداقة بيننا
الدول
توج تحسن اليوم بالتوقيع
اتفاقيات شراكة شاملة و
التعاون الاستراتيجي
التوقيع على هذه المعاهدة سيفتح جديد
الفصل في تاريخ تفاعلنا و
سيوفر آفاق طويلة الأجل و
آفاق جديدة رفعنا الدعوة و
التعاون الثنائي و
العلاقات الثنائية على أساس نوعي
مستوى جديد
عندما تحب durlesty على Miss roucel
قطع القش على 1 مليون ل
نفسي عمودي أنا سخيف itar tass u بعيدا
الدرجات فبراير أوداري وولف الجيوش dnr bdsch
باين سا عالية
كما أود أن أشير إلى أننا اليوم
تحدث مع الرئيس بوتين
إعلان عام 2020 عاما رائعا
عام الثقافة بين مصر وروسيا و
آمل أن يكون ذلك خلال هذا العام
سيكون هناك أنشطة مختلفة
قادرة على التفكير
عمق الحضارة الثقافية و
الروابط الفنية بيننا
الدول والشعوب الصديقة
سلسلة ، فأنت لا تزال طريقة أفانيسوف
روسيا سالب 100 نقطة وحتى فوق
قناة جبل
السحلية عند مستوى كل التفاصيل بالنسبة لي
فيلم الشخصي المينا بالضبط أنا أو صانع
فارغة
10 والسكر يجدونها تعرف ذلك
أعدك وكيف حالنا مع اللون الأزرق الفاتح المليء بالحيوية
يأخذ الخوف
بعد اختيار نموذج عامل المنجم
مثل الأبيض القاسي كان كل شيء يتغير ، نعم هذا كل شيء
السيدات والسادة بجانب التعاون
تهدف مصر وروسيا إلى توفير
مستقبل أفضل لشعوبنا
يتم التنسيق بيننا
القضايا الإقليمية الموضعية
بناء على ثقتنا في
ذات أهمية قصوى لاستعادة
الأمن والاستقرار في هذا
المنطقة في منطقة الشرق الأوسط بذلك
بحيث ترضي مصالح الشعوب
المنطقة ومستقبل أفضل مضمون 2
شبابه بعد فترة طويلة
تعاني من الحرب والدمار
اتصالات من خلالها إلى شاشات الكريستال السائل + واي فاي
كتل كتلة روسيا
دوائر تجميد الغابات الأخرى أو للمخطط
تقي تغلب على علامة المتصرف
وهو أيضًا ما إذا كانت ألينا سيئة أم
تجول في فلسطين وأليس ليدل
تمكنت ساعة litvinovka آل لرمي
جمع غرف حقول أوستن بخلاف الهيليوم و
جيوش السلامي الهيدروجين في هذا السياق نحن
ناقش انتشار بوتين اليوم
المشكلة الفلسطينية وذكرها
وجود تقارب كبير في المواقف
مصر وروسيا على فلسطين
عملية السلام الإسرائيلية
لقد أكدنا أيضًا على أنه لا يتزعزع
مواقف لا تتزعزع فيما يتعلق
الحاجة إلى برنامج شامل
قرار عادل
المشكلة الفلسطينية على اساس
مبدأ الدولتين 2 شعبان
داخل حدود 1967 عملاً بـ
قرارات دولية وعربية
مبادرة السلام
كومو هيسر هي دروس في حبل المشنقة أ
الجاني المنتخب لمشروع القانون قاد الأميد
عرض التبعية مكان النبيذ سيغ الفاسد
روسيا aurezina
إنها متراصة من فيدل مازيبين ، ثم بين
الناس ليسوا كذلك
شقوق دار السبات مع فحم هوميروس
أوليسي
اهتماما خاصا خلال المفاوضات نحن
مكرسة لتطوير الأحداث في سوريا في هذا
الأسئلة اتفقنا على الحاجة
تنسيق التشاور المستمر
لذلك بين مصر وروسيا
موضوع الساعة واتفقنا على
رأي حول ما هو مطلوب
العمل على منع المزيد
تصعيد الأوضاع على الأرض في سوريا في
أوصي بهذا ، هذا هو حقًا 2
ذرات القليل من أتامان إجنات
شهود و فدادين من ursa مطاردة الظلام
إلخ. أنت تماطل في المشهد المهزوم ذو العلامات التجارية
جلسة المخدرات في ابن ليلي ألين
الآلاف من هاتوبا الساطعة ووجدت طعامًا
الزيارات apu تصب فعل سوريا
نقوم بتوريد هذه oleg لهم وفي هذا
وافق السياق على أن يسمى
المبعوث الخاص للأمم المتحدة أوفر
تسريع عملية التشكيل
لجنة التكييف في أسرع وقت ممكن
الوقت كخطوة مهمة ل
تهيئة الظروف اللازمة
2 بشأن استئناف السياسية
المفاوضات وتحقيق شامل
القرار السياسي الذي
من شأنه أن يرضي قانونهم وآمالهم
سلسلة الشعب الأخوي مع الادخار
فخر النزاهة الحقيقية للسوريين
دولة الخل والديون أو حزمة الظهر
التتار والبوق سيد أو سيد
تم استدعاء العرافين جنب وملكة
بطولات الدوري التي تشارك في الإبلاغ عنها بشأن الأيدي اللعينة
هل هذا نائب الرئيس biomah أم من محبي رافائيل
فيلم
الاستيلاء على السواحل من هذا الخارج
بدلة شطيرة للتحليل أنا من و Philibert
أولغا أنوسوفا
تم دفع الأديان و Temkin مع الحاويات إلى المعايير
أما بالنسبة لأحداث الإسبان سواء أنتم نحن
ناقش أحدث التطورات داخل
هذه الأزمة في الاتجاه السياسي
وفي اتجاه الأمن المتبادل
الآراء و
الغناء yip y العمل الاحزاب المختلفة
المتورط في الأحداث الليبية في هذا
السياق ، أطلعت الرئيس بوتين
مع رؤية مصر السياسية و
القرار السياسي في جباية وأنا
أطلع الرئيس
الجهود المهنية لتوحيد
الجيش الوطني الليبي
الأداء الفعال لمهمتها
يكفي الموقد وعندما تكون أنت فقط
تونيك إيران لقاء هذا 1st
سفينة zarathustra مجنون.
أليل 0 مزيد من الألوان أو للطي
كون سيدي جوزيه أنا فنادق سهلة و
لاحظت الامتيازات وعندما منشئ المحتوى
نماذج قانون السجون 5f الفيزيائيين
حامل 28 ص snc إما حقيقي أو
بيا هي الركض لقد ناقشنا أيضا
عواقب الاشتباكات الأخيرة في
طرابلس التي ظهرت بوضوح
ما مدى خطورة وشحذ العد
تشكيل مسلح في القيمة المطلقة السؤال
وسلامة الكبد يؤمنون وأن هذا
يجب أن تكون المهمة (أ) على وجه الحصر
خدمة الجيش النظامي مقرن
الأمن والقانون والنظام نحن
أكد أيضا بحاجة إلى صور
التطبيق الصارم للمبادرة
مبعوثة الأمم المتحدة إلى ليبيا حسنة تنام
سلام من قبل جميع أعضاء المطلوبين
بما في ذلك تجنب الآخرين
جعلك هذا كانت رائعة
الطايا الجديدة روح ألتيما سارات حدق في
الشريط في حالة السياحة الطائرة في هذا كله
معالج جيد أنا
بينر من راشيل ماريا باريير تازة
أفضل اليورانيوم الثعابين إيه ليبي القديمة
نعتقد أن البحث عن حلول موازية
يؤدي فقط إلى إطالة أمد الأزمة و
تفاقم الخلافات بين
الدول الليبية وتعتبر مماثلة
الإجراءات غير التوافقية
معلمات اختبار حقيقة المذنب ألامين
أطروحة عند حد طول الدوري الدوري
الابن الذي حتى النهاية سيحاصر
ليليرا لديها رضاعة آمنة للولادة
تلاحظ ليلي روبن إيما واحدة من السكر أو
وبيلاروسيا
Collared Me Million Fish Spaghetti Strip جون
مع ذلك قفل المدير إلغاء
أوبل لامور ويلر يكون في حمالة الصدر
وعد ميسور التكلفة في المنبر
أذنه إلى النبات ويسيطر على المينا في الدورة
مفاوضات مع الرئيس بوتين
وافق على الحاجة إلى تعزيز
عملية تبادل المعلومات بين
خدمات خاصة لبلداننا في
في مكافحة الإرهاب
خاصة فيما يتعلق بموضوع النقل
الإرهابيين من المناطق غير المستقرة في
الدول الأخرى وأين تلتزم
هل أنت سعيد بالهجوم الإرهابي الجديد الذي أكدناه
أيضا الحاجة إلى القمع
أنشطة لانتقال هذه
الإرهابيين من خلال الحكومة
الحدود ووافق أيضا
الحاجة إلى مشاركة المعلومات حول هذه
الأشخاص مع دول أخرى و
المنظمات الدولية عندما
النخبوية تتلاشى في روسيا
والبضائع كرة الدعارة ايم جدا ليديا لك
لمعرفة المزيد يستريح الزوج من السرطان
لهذه الهواية أو لديك رجل آخر
جاءت مسابقة النمور ترحب بخطب التبن
مشغل تاشير
فندق القدم قاد تلك الصور حتى fae
حرمانه من الحفارين
أكدت في هذا السياق الاستعداد
مصر لتوثيق التعاون مع
روسيا في هذا المجال
تأخذ في الاعتبار أن لدينا
البلد شركاء تقليديون
أو المواقف المشتركة ، المشتركة والعامة ، بعد كل شيء ، لا
في هذا التحدي الخطير
مما يهدد الاستقرار في المنطقة
أنا أيضا
المقدمة للسيد الرئيس
لمحة موجزة عن نتائج عملية شناي
2018 مؤامرة نجاح غير مشروط
التي والنجاحات التي تحققت في الداخل
ويظهر لك نجاح جهود مصر ل
محاربة الإرهاب
المعلمة من الجلوس عند أسد مرات في الأذن
في دليل من الخرز a la ، نعم ، هذا كل شيء
صلى المعالجون أنا retrus i letter بدون
mecha belmes kit natalia talerov from li
الاستراتيجية والتعريفات أحارب الناس هنا
هذه لكنها قلت له أسعد جولة الخلافة
ثور تذكرة ليمويل طن ثم الموقد و
هاجمني السكر في بيرم ما زلت تمساحًا
المزيد من صائدي الكرامب مع رئيساتي السيدات
والسادة نيابة عنهم
شخصيا ونيابة عن الشعب المصري
أريد فقط أن أشكر الرئيس بوتين
للدعوة الكريمة لزيارة روسيا
أريد أن أؤكد على الشخصية الأخرى
العلاقات الاستراتيجية التاريخية
بين بلدينا وأكثر
تنميتها
لمزيد من التطوير الذي نحن عليه
نتطلع إلى قريبا
تلبية الشاي ليس شعوبنا
الاستقرار والتنمية شكرا جزيلا لكم
خلف
[تصفيق]